what do you think about tulsa gabbard
what do you think about tulsi you know
tulsi and i got along well on the trail
um so that's one of the underrated
things about that set of experiences is
that you know it's like people respond
to us and you've probably met a lot of
us so you know to us you're we're hum to
you we're human beings but um you know
to each other it's like i've hung out
with tulsi and her husband abraham you
know like a dozen times and the sticks
of new hampshire are just like you know
waiting to go on in the union hall or
whatnot
so so
uh you know she and i um uh became quite
friendly why why do you think
the left doesn't support her i mean you
got a woman
who is marketable you got a democrat you
got a military she's young
great speaker very good communicator why
do you think the establishment doesn't
elevate somebody like her why do you
think they don't like somebody like her
it was very obvious oh i mean
she had like an open feud going with
hillary yeah going back and forth yeah
she calls her a russian asset whether he
calls tulsi that yeah uh so i'll just
tell you know a story that might be fun
and bring everyone back but i was
actually standing between chelsea
gabriel and kamala harris on the debate
station they're going at it it was
almost a comfortable thing i was like
you know you can actually probably
rewind that footage and see me being
like just like my head go back and forth
like this in the moment are you actually
uncomfortable oh i wasn't uncomfortable
i was like oh my gosh like i can't
believe i'm standing between these two
people um you know going going after you
why do you think so by the way i got to
tell you
folks i want to give andrew yanks a lot
of credit here i got to give you credit
in my mind i'm trying to calculate how
many questions you actually directly
answered i want to say it's less than 50
percent you become a bro you become a
pro and i pride myself
you
there's coaching to to running for
office and you got to figure out a way
and and you've you've given the
politically correct diplomatic answer
nothing that's going to rub anybody the
wrong way so you're playing it safe the
way you're going which maybe it's a
political strategy you got i don't know
maybe you don't want to get that kind of
publicity with all of a sudden andrew
yanks said the following on this podcast
and he pisses five you know 50 000
people up and you don't want to have
that happen to you but your audience is
bigger than that i'm kidding but but i
want to ask you i want to ask you like
specifically why do you think they don't
support somebody like tulsi why not get
behind somebody like tulsi the the way
that the media builds up uh their take
on candidates you know is born of a
number of things i think for tulsi
um
she
came out as being against certain
establishment positions relatively early
uh and then when some reporters went and
tried to
spend time with her you know like some
of the treatment was not good and so you
ended up developing like this really
adversarial relationship which as a
candidate uh you know it's tough because
you feel like if if i sit down with you
and have a conversation with you and
like we have an interview and then the
article comes out and it's
mean and negative then you're like oh
like i spent some time and i tried to
you know like open myself up some and
then you were
kind of harsh to me so let me stop doing
that and then you stop doing that and
then you know what happens
another harsh article comes out
because you're not willing because you
know
the person so so uh so those things can
build up
um pretty pretty quick uh and tulsi
uh i think marches to her own
um her own beat and everyone sensed that
and so when she would be willing to take
on certain establishment figures i think
that made it worse with the press and
that's not a compliment to the press
you know
part of that the fact that she had beef
with the lady in charge hillary clinton
and they were like uh uh buddy like
you're barking up the wrong tree or her
uh going after kamal on the debate stage
i think that was another thing
yeah
kamala kamala or tulsi can you imagine
like
um
the two on how they deliver messages
kamala versus tulsi a hundred at a
hundred times tulsi is going to do laps
around kamal do you think so
a thousand had a thousand times do you
agree in a method or yeah delivering
message now he may disagree with it i
don't know
he was in the state on stage with the
both of them they would know they're
different types of figures they're
different types of messengers uh you
know that they are i've seen them both
speak like a an awful lot of times most
of the time in a forum where no one else
was paying any attention it was like you
know those are the best though yeah you
know um uh it it it was
a fascinating process i recommend if
this thing happens again which it will
in 24 it's like just spend a weekend in
in new hampshire or iowa if you're close
to those things because you can see all
the candidates up close if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]